anyways yeah I would say feminists girls
that like are super only fans club like
that sort of thing and
um
whales number one is Wales do you know
why they hate you my perception like the
way I feel about it is that they hate
you because you're saying stuff there's
truth to it if there wasn't truth to
what you were saying they wouldn't hate
you they would just be like oh who cares
yeah there's truth to it and also it
makes them reflect on their own choices
so now if you're talking about how
female promiscuity is not empowering and
they've been promiscuous and they bought
the story that that was somehow
empowering they're listening to you and
they're like we gotta shut her up see
and here's the thing a lot of times we
have this narrative like oh they bought
the story when they're young I don't
really believe that I think a deep down
on an innate level we all know because
what's the first thing that girls call
each other when we're mad you're a hoe
why are you saying that if it's a good
thing I feel like sometimes that's a
cop-out that women use well they'll be
like oh I bought it and I'm like did you
did you